hi matthew
hello
hello so matthew devi is our next
speaker and matthew is a solution
architect at aws as a technology
enthusiast maker on his free time and he
likes challenges and solving problems of
clients and users
works with talented people to learn
every day and today he will talk to us
about the aws ml vision which is making
machine learning accessible to all
customers
and so i'm just going to add the video
to the stream and then we'll just go
back to the q a
hello i'm mature solution architect at
aws thank you for joining and i hope
that you will enjoy that session today
we will learn the adobe's vision and
services for machine learning and how to
convert a notebook to train on sagemaker
you will need
during the presentation to connect to a
temporary degree second so we will get
to that so let's jump into it the
adwords vision is to make the machine
learning accessible to all the customers
if you are developer data scientist of
business user doesn't matter we have
some service for you the adobe sml stack
is composed of three layer the bottom
layer is all the infrastructure where
you can find the gpu the cpu
the imi for the most popular frameworks
on the top layer you have the ai
services
it's the machine learning model that is
bundled as an api so you can leverage
them to answer your application and
provide some amazing feature for your
user and the middle stack is the sage
maker and we will go deep into that
this year we've signed a partnership
with ugginface that will reinforce the
adobe's vision
and that partnership focus on nlp and
how to make it easy and accessible for
everyone
with these new partnerships you can now
leverage the dlc container that is
developed with agin face to train and do
the inference for your favorite
frameworks
we also provide an estimator directly
integrated in the sagemaker sdk that
helps to deploy nfp script and train it
on sagemaker
we have a comprehensive
gallery of example
that you can find online
and support wise it's maintained and
supported by adobe s
so now that you have an overview of the
adobe software
let's dive deeper into this searchmaker
architecture and how it works
everything starts
with a
notebook
it could be something else but usually
it's what we have that notebook can run
on sagemaker or on your laptop
inside that notebook you will use the
sagemaker sdk with the sagemaker and
nikkei you will call the method fit on
your estimator
that will
launch
a training job
this training job will leverage
an easier
registry
where all the
dlc for all the frameworks are stored
we will train and output
the model
to
adobe's
s3
so now that you have your model
you can
then deploy your model using the sdk
so you will call
the department method
and
that will create
a model
inside changemaker
that will reference
the model that you have stored in s3
from there
the sdk will continue by creating
an endpoint configuration
and then
an endpoint
of course this endpoint
will leverage the endpoint configuration
and the run configuration will leverage
the model
then
the
the
the endpoint will pull the image
from the registry to serve your request
and your users
can access the inference from the
endpoint
so now that you understand the sage
maker architecture
let's do an example by
modifying an existing notebook
to train it on sagemaker
so today we will use that particular
repository as an example
so i already check out on my computer
and as you can see in the train
notebook
we have a older notebook with the import
we read the data
we define the model
and the tokenizer
we process the data to split it
after we just create
the data sets
we compile the model with keras
and after we call the method fit
after
the training is done
we save the model
and we do a bit of evaluation
so the goal today is to take that script
and convert it to search maker
in vs code i can just say export to
python script
and here i will remove all the
unnecessary commands
now we have a clean script when
sagemaker will
call your script he will pass a couple
of parameter with to know where is the
location of your data and the output of
your model let's pass those arguments
for that we will need to import a couple
of library
and create a function wrapper
then we will need to use this parameter
inside of script
as you can see there we have a custom
hyper parameter that is called epoch so
we will use it also to dynamize our
script
last thing is the model evaluation
we don't have a specifically an
interface because we are in script mode
so we will need to export a json with
the model to be able to evaluate
it now we are good
let's just save this file
we will create a new folder called
script
and create the trend
dot p
file
our script is ready so we will start a
new notebook and use the sagemaker sdk
to create and train our model
first thing we need to import the
sagemaker sdk
and
create a couple of variables to store
the session the whole execution the erm
role that will be used by sagemaker to
train our model
the bucket where we will save our model
artifact and a prefix inside that bucket
to make sure it's well organized
for the moment our data live inside the
project so we will transfer them to s3
to be able force maker to use it inside
a training job
we're gonna import the bottle free sdk
and upload it to s3 we can start using
the sagemaker sdk to create the aginface
sc matter
there you can see that we specify the
endpoint with our training job
we precise the source directory that is
script all the code inside script will
be
send to s3 and host inside the deep
learning container
we were gonna use a p3
two weeks large for that training
only one
and we can precise the frameworks
version
here you have your hyper parameter where
you can pass some custom variable to
your script
like the import one
now we have everything so we just need
to call the fit method on our
exterminator
inside it we will
pass a channel called train with
the information and the pastor or data
in s3
so let's run the script
no credential error
it's true we didn't set up or i do play
a second you should have received an
email with the necessary information to
connect to the event engine platform
so from there
copy your team ash
and accept the term
login
for that session we will use
the email one-time password
type your email
and pass the code that you receive
inside that email
you are now connecting to your team
dashboard so you can click the adwords
custom button
and
click open the adwords console
there you have access to the console and
we will just set up and go to the search
maker
page
but because we are running our script
locally inside the s code we will need
to have some credential to export inside
our environment
for that just come back to your event
engine tab
and grab the key
here
switch back to vs code
and create
a dot
of
file
where you will print your variables
remove the export
in front of your variable
register it so now we need to load our
environment inside the notebook
so create a new code session
and
and load it with a dot amp
and clean all the outputs and run or
notebook
now your job is launched inside
sagemaker so let's see it
so inside save maker
go to training and training job and
there you have your training job
running so you can see the details
but also you have all the logs coming
inside your notebook let's wait the job
to complete
[Music]
the training is now complete so let's
see in sage maker what's happened
so we can see that the statue is
completed and when you scroll on the
bottom you will see the output so click
on it
and there you have the two
output artifact from the model
the model himself and the output where
you will have
the evaluation so let's download them
so inside the output
zip
we have all the information about the
model
we also have our model
with the h5 files the tokenizer and the
config with appearance
so as you will have if you train it
locally
now that we have our model we can easily
deploy it with the sagemaker sdk
so for that
create a new cell
and from the estimator called the deploy
method
you specify the initial
account instance
and the instance type it will create a
predictor for you
that process will take a couple of
minutes just the time to deploy the
endpoint
[Music]
deployment is complete so let's see in
sagemaker what has been created
so if i come back to sage maker
you see in the inference part
that we have
one model
pointing
to or model artifact
a new endpoint configuration
with all model selected there
and for traceability you also have the
training job that produced that model
the instance
and the initial count
and finally
the endpoint
with the http url for that
so now that everything is in place we
just have to test our own point
for that
we will
had a sentence
from a
movie comment
and use the predictor to predict over
that sentence
and we see that it's positive
and 99
if you don't use anymore on points
to don't be sharp for it
you can finish that workshop by just
deleting it
for that use the predictor delete
endpoint command
i hope you enjoyed the session and thank
you for having me i cannot wait to see
what you will do with sagemaker
okay welcome back that's it
thanks
so
i think uh everything is still online
and it's new out so we're still still
alive great
um maybe
i think there's a few questions i saw
maybe you want to ask matthew about his
talk
sure
um
so one first question is um
so it seems like sagemaker stores the
fine-tuned model and s3 is it also
possible to push the model to the egging
face hub
yes of course you you can so the the
script that you will run inside
sagemaker is a python basic pattern
strip so you can add your credential uh
in uh on by on manual from the hub and
push it to the the the thing that you
will lose uh with that is uh to be able
to deploy the endpoint with the
sagemaker deployment point uh method
because
you rely on the
on the fact that the model is indeed
free
that makes sense and speaking of those
end points do the endpoints deployed by
sagemaker automatically scale under i
load
so you need a bit of configuration for
that to to create an alarm inside
cloudwatch based on the metric that you
will define and the best way to to do it
is like to test your model uh in the
load testing environment to define uh
like this threshold maybe you will have
thousands of requests by second that can
be handled by one instance
and you can create an alarm from by
instance request count
and it will automatically scale against
that and you can precise the maximum
number of instances and the the minimum
number
nice
going back to the models that you used
can i finish you in any patron model in
sagemaker or only some architecture
supported
so all the architecture that is
supported by again face can be trained
on sagemaker we directly partner with a
egg in face to to to include
the transformer library and the dataset
library directly on the dlc so
everything that is supported by those
libraries will be supported in
sagemaker very cool very cool
um
another question that we just received
on the forum is uh is there anything
sort of like tool to monitor model
training on search maker
yes we we have something that is called
model monitor
so you put some call back and you attach
some code back during the training and
you will
just send the matrix to it and you have
reports inside
the sagemaker studio id
where you can have that and of course
you can leverage tensorboard also and
weight and base is connected to it
nice uh a question more related to the
to the event for the next three days uh
what kind of gpu slash instances can we
use during the event
so you can use the the p3
instances
but you can run
into some issue of availability uh
with them so if you re encourage those
issue you can switch to a gcat dnr
that will be a bit slower
but also it's like the new gpu where you
can leverage uh the fps 16 so so it
could be also a good fit for training
the models
and also something that i didn't precise
because we didn't send the email with
the invitation to the event engine so it
will come
shortly when we have the team that are
build and so please share your email
inside the google form and so we can
invite you
to those icons
same thing so it's a good time luis to
show again uh where where we can
fill that form if you want to share your
screen on the forums sure one second
so yeah so
if you're um
gonna be
participating in building projects for
the course then we have all these
different project ideas on the forums
but
this is all under the the course
category or the course projects category
and the thing that you'll want to look
for for information is this post about
the course projects category
and here there's the information about
the kind of rules for the team numbers
and you'll find here that there's a form
that you need to fill in to get access
so if you click on that link this will
take you to this google form you just
need to put in your email
and whether or not you want to get some
goodies from aws
and then you just provide your username
on the huge face hub so we can
associate you with your account and then
you just provide here the name of the um
the team that you're working on um so
that we can then figure out which people
are working together
so once you've done that you'll then um
be given access i think from tomorrow
um to
create your sagemaker jobs and then the
last thing you want to do is we have a
sagemaker community
organization on the hub
and this is also where
if you want during the training you can
push your models here so
i think we'll learn about this in the
next talk
and then you can also deploy your spaces
here if you wish you can deploy your
spaces on your own account but if you
want to put them here you're welcome to
do so
uh i don't think
we had any other questions there is
unless you had uh
got something in mind
um no i think i think that's uh i'd say
it was a super nice talker i like the
dancing
thanks
he make a bit of fun
yeah definitely
thanks a lot for joining us today